there
are different rules for different people
we're seeing this not just
in the government
we're seeing this in the so-called
private sector though the private sector
seems pretty public to me we're seeing
this in big tech and facebook there's a
big report just came out in the wall
street journal
facebook says its rules apply to all
company documents reveal a secret elite
that is exempt so there's this program
known as x check that gives millions of
celebrities politicians another profile
users high profile users the privilege
to
get around the rules and this is not
some conspiracy theory this has been
revealed from internal facebook
documents that say for for certain
people they're not going to be held to
the same standard and that's that
now
sometimes i i
show different reactions to these sorts
of stories on a scale broke woke and
bespoke okay so the broke take which is
what the libs are
rattling on about right now is that this
is a good thing it's good that dr fauci
for instance
hypothetically could be exempted from
certain rules it's good that the left
gets to play by easier rules than the
right does okay
that's that's the broke take the woke
take the little bit a little bit smarter
take is that this is bad everyone should
be equal everyone should have to play
exactly on the same level playing field
on facebook as everyone else that's
definitely a better take than the left
should be given special privileges but i
i don't even think that quite gets it a
lot of conservatives are pushing that
that argument right now but i don't
think that even quite gets it
i would suggest the bespoke take the the
more perceptive one which is
hierarchies in politics are inevitable
there are this is a very conservative
understanding of human nature and
political communities there are going to
be hierarchies there is going to be an
elite there are people are going to be
in different positions and it's just the
way human nature works just the way
politics works
what is really bad about this
is that mark zuckerberg should not be
setting the political order
yes i grant you this is kind of my point
on free speech when when the the right
reacted to the left's manipulation of
our free speech
regime and said well you should be able
to say whatever you want and do whatever
you want i'm a free speech absolutist
and i just think that's
a silly argument it's a utopian argument
even that's not that's never been true
anywhere certainly not in america even
free speech has never meant you can say
whatever you want whenever you want to
say it every society has stan has
standards and taboos the question to me
that's more interesting is
who sets those standards who sets those
taboos what are they going to be what's
the same exact principle here who sets
the political hierarchy
who's who sets the way that the
privilege and status is doled out in
society that's going to be inevitable
that's going to happen but why is this
one billionaire oligarch in silicon
valley why is he the one doing it
we used to at least live in a
constitutional republic where where we
the people did that sort of thing where
our political system did that sort of
thing but now
these these elites
these oligarchs in silicon valley run
that political system because they
control speech
and that is a political act
and part of that is the result it's not
just the result of the left grabbing
power it's the result of the right
becoming obsessed with this idea of
privatization and government always bad
and politics always bad and corporations
good and so we've just given our
politics to the corporations now the
corporations run our politics and we
have even less of a say in it
that doesn't make very much sense to me
you've got to step in and reassert an
authentic political order i'm so glad
you liked that clip if you want to check
out the whole show which i would
strongly recommend go to apple podcast
spotify stitch or google play type in
the michael knowles show
subscribe leave us a five star review we
really appreciate it see you next time
[Music]
[Music]